in order to learn so using this
policy which was published in 2019
we have 74 programs today using the
middle tier
acquisition pathway including the army's
integrated visual augmentation system
or ivas use of rapid prototyping
and the new authorities afforded by the
mta pathway
allowed the program to shave significant
time from the schedule
streamline metrics to better inform
decisions and reporting
and provide greater flexibility to
manage risk
as a result ivas intends to rapidly
field the capability
in fiscal year 21 after conducting
dozens of hardware prototypes and
thousands of software builds
through continuous iteration with
soldiers
this would represent only 34 to 36
months from
program start to feeling capability for
the war fighter
the mta pathway incentivized powerful
behaviors across the acquisition
enterprise
to quickly restore the army's advantage
in individual situational awareness
navigation communications and target
acquisition
i'm also pleased to see emerging
programs
utilizing the flexibility of the entire
aaf
i recently saw a service proposal to
begin a program
using the mta pathway before
transitioning into a traditional major
capability pathway
another program is proposing to use
several of the pathways
in combination to facilitate rapid
delivery of capability
while these plans are still under review
i'm excited to see the acquisition
community
embracing creative compliance to use
these new tools and authorities
while demonstrating critical thinking
hybrid approaches like these allow
program managers
in partnership with functional leaders
and their decision authority
to start programs quickly drive down
risk and solidify detailed requirements
and engineering approaches
while still ensuring the proper level of
analysis
risk management and oversight similarly
the software pathway the aaf's newest
policy
signed just last week represents a
substantial departure
from the department's usual way of doing
business the acquisition enablers team
has worked to deliver the software
policy rapidly
given the interest from the services and
osd partners
in fact the team may have set a new
acquisition
policy conceptualization to publication
record
it took nine months to move from an
interim
to a final policy this is three months
earlier than promised
and one year earlier than congressional
expectations
technology is accelerating and
disrupting business models
and we must adapt accordingly to keep
pace
and close the knowledge gap given that
software is central to
every dod mission and system we must
acquire
and deliver software with greater speed
agility and cyber security
stemming from the defense science board
and defense innovation board's
software acquisition and practices or
swap study
the software pathway is designed to
enable
continuous integration and delivery of
software capabilities
recognizing that modern software
development is a continuum
from development to production and
drawing sustainment
the pathway is built upon commercial
principles
that enable innovation and swift
delivery
in response to conditions of uncertainty
such as rapidly changing user needs
disruptive technologies and threats on
the battlefield
by removing procedural bottlenecks and
regulatory bureaucracy
programs are pushed to embrace the goal
of delivering capabilities
with much faster cycle times in one year
or less
while emphasizing and ensuring cyber
security
a great example of this is the air
force's ground-based strategic deterrent
or gbsd
a critical program requiring
uncompromised security
dependability and 24 7 availability
coupled with digital engineering to
support unprecedented speed
and clarity during industry reviews the
program
is leveraging modern iterative
development practices
like agile and development security and
operations or def
ops methodologies gbsd's
devsecops enterprise services and
infrastructure support mission
requirements
while streamlining the acquisition
process
and have allowed the program to gain
accreditation
and begin early development with
industry
in less than four months the navy's
combines
compiled to combat in 24 hours or c2
c24 is also employing devsec ops
and other modern software practices to
move towards
rapid capability insertion with speed
scale and rigor pilot programs conducted
by the navy
indicate the effort is making progress
towards its goal
of deploying new software capabilities
to ships afloat
in under 24 hours a game-changing
improvement from the typical 18-month
time frame
in addition to each of the aaf's
pathways
it's also important to highlight that
the 5000
series redesign includes dod
instructions
for overarching functional areas such as
intellectual
intellectual property product support
and
cyber security creation
of a new dod instruction for cyber
security
for example will provide the acquisition
community
consistent guidance to implement
appropriate
cyber processes and practices
for every acquisition throughout the
supply chain
regardless of which aaf pathway is used
this new policy which we expect to be
signed out
later this month ensures cyber hardening
is designed in at the beginning of a
program and ties
in closely to our cyber security
maturity model certification
or cmmc program similarly
under bob beeler's leadership creation
of the test
and evaluation instruction is game
changing
it encourages better coordination and
integration
between developmental and operational
testing
resulting in cost savings and
accelerated test
programs in conjunction with the aaf
pathways
these functional area policies ensure
delivered systems
are sustainable upgradable affordable
exportable and secure throughout the
entire
life cycle these functional area
policies
are available on our acquisition
enablers website
so what's next in this acquisition
innovation effort
from the onset the aaf was designed to
be a living document
to provide our defense acquisition
system an adaptable
responsive foundation capable
of satisfying emerging requirements we
are focused on ensuring we provide the
right tools
to deliver end-to-end operation
operational capability
and we are exploring the creation of
additional
acquisition pathways to address unique
systems
for example the department is working
with the space force
to determine whether there are any tools
missing and is committed
to developing a tailored space vehicle
pathway
if needed additionally restructuring
policy and governance
is only one piece of the puzzle we
continue to drive
hard along each of our other acquisition
lines of effort contracting at speed of
relevance
strengthening and securing our defense
industrial base
and effectively training our acquisition
workforce
when it comes to our tremendous
acquisition professionals
i'd like to highlight the launching of
our back to basics initiative
the first major reform of the defense
acquisition workforce management
framework
in nearly three decades like the aaf
we are pivoting from a one-size-fits-all
certification construct
to a component and workforce centric
tailorable
continuous learning construct by
streamlining the structure of the
workforce
into six functional areas this shift to
modern talent management
will empower the workforce for success
today
and in the future in closing we still
have work to do
but i couldn't be more proud of the
momentum we've generated
i want to thank you for the opportunity
to discuss these milestones with you
and their impact on the way the
department acquires
and delivers capability to our war
fighters with that
kevin stacey and i welcome your
questions thank you
all right let's go to the phones first
uh tony capaccio bloomberg
hi miss lord thanks for the update i
have a question on how the
the new acquisition adaptive strategy
will apply to the navy's
battle force 2045 gold that the
secretary laid out yesterday
you know that the navy has had a history
of cost overruns
delays on all its major programs for the
last 15 years
what tenants of the new strategy
might help break that paradigm of poor
performance
let me make um just a couple comments
tony and then i'll turn it over
to kevin and stacy i think as you know
the navy was a big part of designing
this aaf
um they also have many
low volume high complexity high cost
ships that they develop ships and subs
so we're looking
at potential pathways to address
these very issues what we want to do
is make sure that we give the navy
flexibility
to be able to design contracts that
incentivize the behavior
from our industry partners that we need
to deliver capability rapidly but
compliantly with all of our requirements
with that i'll hand over
to kevin and stacy yeah i'd add a few
things right first and foremost is part
of
miss lord's creative compliance is also
focused on
basically having acquisition data and
data informed decisions right
so part and partial to everything we're
doing
basically right now on all major
acquisition programs uh
we report to the deputy every month on
the status of all the programs and to
the secretary every six weeks right
and so that gives you real-time data to
show where the status of the program is
in addition to that to the programs uh
like columbia right that miss lord is
still the milestone decision authority
she has semi-annual reviews of those
programs
which the focus is on data right so tony
to answer your question as part of that
process we continue to ask
you know we're thinking the adaptive
framework really
is adaptive that you can you can tailor
it
for specific capabilities you're doing
and how do we focus on data-driven
decisions so we have to do
as you know all the decisions we make
are focused on when do i need the data
to make the decision i'm making
so we have that construct around the
adaptive framework
and we are talking with with the navy
are there things because
ship building is uh unique right it's an
eight-year development process for an
individual boat
are there things that aren't covered in
the adaptive framework that will
continue to have those dialogues
right that's good all right okay
uh carson do you have a question yeah
thank you very much for doing this miss
lord
you emphasized the national defense
strategies importance in
framing this uh aaf uh
one of the lines of defense national
defense strategy
one of the lines of efforts in this
strategy document is
partnership building partnership and
strengthen alliances
so we have seen that we've seen reports
that some
key members of the congress either
individually or
collectively have quietly frozen all
major arms sales to
turkey over the course of last two years
apart from the f-35 program and an s-400
uh crisis uh quagmire turkey has been a
long-standing to
defense partner of the united states
have you ever raised this issue with the
congressional leaders
in that respect we
constantly talk with congress about
international relations whether it be
our supply base
or um exporting and in fact
right now we have an effort under
secretary esper
that we call defense trade modernization
where we are trying
to at the outset of programs
um designing exportability and we are
also
constantly looking at what we can
release
in terms of technology so we do
look at um each of the aors under the
cocoms and we constantly
evaluate what we will export and what we
want
so is it a concern for you that by doing
this the congress
is somehow pushing a partner away from
the united states or not
we we constantly discuss
the pros and cons of a lot of this
your specific question is really a
little bit more in the policy realm
and i defer to my policy colleagues for
that i look at how
we can actually conduct an acquisition
process
to give our policy makers the most
flexibility possible
back to the phones let's go to jackson
of fed scoop
hi thank you i wanted to follow up on
the software
pathway does this have any changes to
the ato
process and could you enumerate if there
was any what were the kind of biggest
bottlenecks that this
rewrite gets rid of and changes thank
you
well i think for the second part of that
and i'll answer it and then i'll hand it
over
to kevin and stacy for any other
comments
the biggest bottleneck the biggest
challenge
with modern software development is that
it's a continuum
from development to production and then
sustainment and it's really a virtuous
cycle
because of the way we receive our funds
um
we have very clearly uh marked
money for each of those three activities
the biggest
challenge is to get a single color of
money if you will
for software so that we can really do
agile
and devsecops and keep going and
congress has
really partnered with us to authorize a
number of pathway
projects that we're just getting going
on with a single color of money
to show how that's an enabler um
in terms of atos what we're doing
is coupling these modern
software development techniques with
our migration to the cloud using
common stacks in the cloud which will do
a number of things for us
once it really enables security of the
code that we are developing
but by using those common stacks we also
get automatic authorities to operate so
all of these things
come together let me hand over to stacy
yeah thank you for that question about
the software pathway so
some of the important aspects of this
policy
include working very closely with the
user community on an iterative basis but
it also moves
to the left so earlier in the program
life cycle
building in cyber security building in
developmental and operational tests
so that we are identifying in the build
of our
software applications leveraging
enterprise solutions
and ability to more quickly get
a testing certification your authority
to operate from a cyber security
perspective
and that's what enables us to deliver
capability
faster for the first time to the user
but also to provide updates that are
cyber secure and meeting the
exact needs of the user because they're
involved up front
and i'll just add right so uh in
addition to what miss lord said right so
the software uh
pathway uh is big on devsecops by
definition devsec ops right is has
security into the software so one of the
big efforts is how do we do better as
both of them said
in reciprocity when one organization
gets an ato
that we can uh give that to other
programs
and then a big part of that which is
another thing that we're working on the
early stages
across the department is the digital
engineering piece right
where we have the information as ms ford
said in the cloud so we have the right
data
that will allow us to better get to an
ato as the data is developed especially
in the software
arena all right let's get in one more
question here
sarah friedman from inside cyber
security did you have one
yes
this is related to the cyber security uh
framework that you're going to be
putting out with cmmc um can you provide
any detail on how that will be tied
to the cmnc program and will be based on
the controls or the maturity levels
yeah um you want me yeah so uh um
yes so basically right now and there has
never been there's an instruction that
talks about cyber security
right and basically you probably know
the whole background on
you know cyber maturity model
certification was
we realized how critical cyber security
is on our programs in our
defense industrial base right and there
was some
thought process that basically says oh
we'll make it a trade-off between cost
schedule performance
our thing was no cyber's a requirement
right and that's where the cmmc
idea came up with the the instruction
it would have been published now
but when the interim rule was published
with the comment period as we pulled it
back
it didn't have cmmc in there because you
can't have it in there until it's a fire
rule
so when it became a interim rule and out
for a
comment miss lord said well why don't we
pull it back and make that uh part of
the
plan so right now that that for the that
should be in the next 60 days
and as you probably know you know this
is a little different usually when a
fire rule goes into effect that
every contract after has to be compliant
is we have a
implementation uh plan over the next
couple years
working with industry and that's one of
the things we're working with the
services and with our industry partners
i'm picking very uh good pilots or or
pathfinders
that show how we will flow down because
part of the instruction explains
just because your prime contract is
level three
it doesn't mean that your level seven
sub supplier is level three that you
need to flow down the requirement and
depending on what that company is
specifically doing it may be a level one
and so that's part of the training and
what the instruction
says is how do you do that critical
thinking of security
and how do you determine what levels as
we slow it down
i think this is a really good example of
the process we've been using where we
get a policy out there and start
using it and learn from it and then
continue to refine it
but again we're getting a minimally
viable product
out there most of the time and getting
the cycles of learning and we will
continue to improve it
and that's what we're trying to do with
acquisition
all right uh we are about out of time so
i wanted to give the team an opportunity
to
make any closing comments and this lord
if you had anything or mr b
i just want to say that i'm incredibly
proud of this team the work that kevin
and stacey have done
incredibly collaborative and i believe
we have irreversible momentum here
in terms of dod acquisition kevin yeah
i would just add the the one thing that
we get asked a lot about
is our relationship if you look at a lot
of these things
it's with other partners across the
department of defense and
with the split of atl the relationships
were different but if you look at the
the tne one which was usually focused on
just operational tests is really
integration of operation and development
which is
also an r e thing and our relationship
with r
e because big part of us being able to
go fast
is how do you mature technology
not only the technology is mature but
it's focused on the capability
that we want to deliver and i would tell
you hypersonics is the poster child on
how
a s and r e is supposed to work that
we're all in that together using the
pathways
even in s t we're thinking about the
capability not the technology maturation
only
so i think that's a big part of it is
working with the other members
you know the cape the comptroller they
all have been part of making this a
reality
absolutely stacy yes the the one thing i
would say is that
the publishing of these policies does
not represent the end of an effort but
the beginning of an effort
and we are going to continue to work
with
uh program teams program managers and
their teams to
look at the policy that we've published
learn from them
and then incorporate improvements that
we hear from the teams
around the country incorporate them in
as lessons learned
so that we can make this policy even
better and continue to deliver to the
warfighter at the speed of relevance
all right thank you everybody i
appreciate your time and we will see you
soon
thank you
you